all right at 607. look to the sky this
afternoon you're going to see maybe
that well not a legion stadium but at
some point there'll be planes flying and
you'll know what i'm talking about it's
the air force thunderbirds
they're doing a special flyover as they
return to nellis air force base from
their show over the weekend
hector mejia live now with some details
about where the sky
and when today you can see them hector
good morning to you
good morning john and that's all
happening in about six hours from now
the air force thunderbirds buzzing over
the las vegas strip again and as they
fly back home
to nellis air force base we'll get to
see another air show
the u.s the thunderbirds started their
2021 season over the weekend in cocoa
beach florida
the team also launched a new show they
hope is more fan friendly for those
watching here from below from earth
as they return home the thunderbirds
will give us another air show as we were
just mentioning and they did this a few
times
last year you might remember so here are
the details for today they're arriving
today between noon and 1pm
and when they do this they take one of
three routes either coming in from the
west from the south to the east
today for those in henderson it's going
to be your lucky day because they're
coming in from the east
flying over henderson green valley and
silver outer ranch
then they're making a turn to roughly
kind of follow the las vegas boulevard
and then the i-15 until they get to the
north part of the valley
and then finally land back home over at
the air force base
and you might remember from previous
times the entire flyby only takes just a
few minutes
so you might miss it if you're not
outside again so they're landing or
they're gonna
arrive between noon and 1pm and
according to their twitter page
they don't have an exact arrival time
because they don't know what time
they're going to
actually fly here exactly because they
might fly through some severe weather
as they make their way back home to las
vegas we have a map on
8newsnow.com in case you want to check
out the route reporting live hector
mejia 8 news now back to you guys hector
thank you very much again if you maybe
don't get a chance to see them
you will hear them maybe head out to the
edges of the valley you can see them zip
right through the center of the valley
good stuff hector thank you very much